On the morning of the great nation's illness, Mamoru-sama clearly experienced what he had
done, and hereby acknowledges his bravery.You are the
only king who can unify China and end the warring states.From now on, in 15 years, you will
destroy all six countries and destroy China.  There is no
doubt that we will enter a great era with six unification wins, and the true
six great generals will be revived. We are sure to seize the first stone of six wins.
Wait, it's
time for the sunset.
This is the black of the battlefield.  It's day, welcome to the ventilation army. We'll
do whatever we want here, so we'll
ventilate with that in mind, you brats.
Learn how to fight like an adult here. If we hold all five hills,
we'll win. Let's go, you guys.
Nako's
battle is going to be complicated as expected.
Zooka suddenly uses Zeno. Her
prey is Ki and body, and I'll
take the head. It's all for the sake of winning.